de dinheiro está saindo nada para nós
gosto passam e aí a gente normal todo
mundo vocês me dá tudo muito um porque
agora tenho de casa nova o amigo velho
essa parede branca e macia
olha que para ele no meu deus a bola de
madeira feito produziram jobs do enviado
da inglaterra a mente pra fazer pra mim
estamos aqui para mais um vídeo novo pra
você em atitude aparecer uma fonte e ela
me deu um presente o que eu e que
presente ou centeio em off the music
playing limite à praia do santos mas
cerca triplo carpado tudo isto de se
fumar estaria me sinto stralis a sair
todo mundo plano diante se tem uma coisa
que eu gosto na minha vida que eu amo é
fone de ouvido é porque ela milionã no
primeiro porque a maioria do tempo
vivido doente agora na minha garganta
inflamada com a garganta inflamada aí
pra gente ficar calado e correcta calado
o que é bom pra gente ouve as coisas bem
como diz aquele ditado quem muito ouvir
ponto fala na na na casa do ferreiro
espeto de madeira então é muito bom
escutar e eu só sei ouvir fone de ouvido
se foi o histórico no entanto que um dos
problemas que você usar fone de ouvido
no máximo é que você canta achando que
tá bonito linda tão linda
esse é o jeito sereno e seu corpo moreno
esse teu olho pequeno que eu não fui
vocês se ilude com o som que você tá
houve na verdade nunca foi bonita
segundo moreno nos pequenos que não anda
lá e olha que nada mudou nem outra coisa
ruim é que toda vez que eu tô com fome
instaurando no máximo mente sempre vem
alguém falar alguma coisa comigo e e
agora tem um disco voador
a imoralidade martins toda a visita que
eles falam do celso portiolli não tente
pessoa ficou fone escutando música alta
a música a sede até dizer sim ou não eu
isso vazou o vídeo arte zapag
pornografia gay um cara beijando outro
fantasma do outro não parece muito com
tinga oscar neto também quero morrer de
enfarte e sim trocar essa [ __ ] de
borracha por essa tv 42 polegadas e não
outro porque eu odeio te escutando
música é porque eu sempre estou
escutando a música eu acho que eu estou
viajando é a coisa mais linda da minha
vida eu me sinto no meu lugar entre si
que é só meu que é só na sentimento da
minha vida e vem um e pede um lado do
fone emprestado com o doido porque faz
isso comigo sabe que precisa só de 2
fone banking eu tô aqui que fosse para
dividir com outra pessoa ia 53 fone dois
pra mim e um para outra pessoa má eu não
divido meu fone por quem não sei nem me
um e nos resta também porque não é este
homem também não dá um sorriso também
olham nos olhos não usar boca na boca
chove também pessoal foi lido o que
cuidar um baixo também houve também beto
o que é o que é que tu quer um ato fone
eu me também ala do fone som só minuto
[Música]
olha os olhos um só o zé alencar não
divido meu fone com ninguém eu não tive
meu fone com ninguém eu quero é ver quem
é no mundo que foi emprestado no fone e
filho para o seu fundo aumentou o tom da
minha mãe porque porque minha mãe é
minha mãe e minha mãe pixotada agora tem
uma coisa que é uma coisa que me deixa
puto que me deixa com rádio com ódio
quando eu tô vindo a coisa é quando tá
chegando a melhor parte da música a
melhor parte da música pode ser uma
frase pode ser um refrão pode ser um
solo toda vez que eu tô enquanto
chegando a melhor parte da música alguém
venha um desgraçado para falar comigo a
música é muito legal na minha vida eu
adoro muito ela e tá chegando a parte
que eu gosto isso e vai vai começar o
solado
eu só queria saber que talvez sim talvez
não só o meu só é bom porque só vai
embora revolta só pra começar agora do
sol o que o deixou de ouvir dalcin você
pega o fone você desenrola fonte enrola
ele com a maior delicadeza precisão tudo
que você sabe o que você aprendeu com o
mestre junina da malásia do capiroto
eterno que vem do deserto da arábia na
capital da zâmbia maldita do deserto
quando você coloca dentro do bolso você
puxa de volta
eu não entendo esse satanismo parece que
tal satã nada do bolso espera um fone de
ouvido a chevron também tem uma desgraça
e toda vez que um estilo fone de ouvido
vai mandar o fone de ouvido pega o fone
desgraça eu quero que você comece você
gosta de ouvir música em fones de ouvido
o que você mais gosta de ouvir no fone
de ouvido quem você mais odeia conta
acontecendo fone de ouvido tanto faz
quero que você comete embarque é lógico
não pode esquecer de dar que clicado
gostei porque clicando aqui
me ajuda demais porque se você não
cuidar não gostei do que toda vez que
você tiver a ouvir um fone de ouvido e
vai aparecer vou pedir um foi pra mim e
se você me der eu cegue chopp time a
terminar a uma vizinha antes de acabar o
dia 14 de junho eu voltar com uma galera
fazendo stand up o teatro da assembléia
e tava ingresso na moral tatu street
lá no sempre tá vendendo ingresso na
moral tattoo street lá do centro a
menina é da radical modos um desceu e na
play rock de seu tomei então queria
pedir para você quer daqui de teresina
que comprasse novo méxico que toda vez
que eu faço todo mundo deixa para
comprar em cima da hora e acaba de
figurino do lado de fora e é paga
seguindo lá de fora e pra ir lá namorar
o ator na playboy ou na radical modo
tiram foto tem grande marca no instagram
o v é o primeiro link na descrição do
vídeo você vai saber tudo direitinho é
que é quanto que é tudo tudo direitinho
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo se
você clicar e ta ai e avisam também que
eu votar no dia 31 no torresmo de lá com
joão meu mundo minha vida cacau e
morango brasileira vai estar uma galera
no concelho doido todo mundo levantar